do I need a patent so a great question
for one of my YouTube viewers Adarsh
love you guys and the dark road in to
say thank you so much Evan that's great
guidance on your side as far as a patent
is concerned is it a good idea to
officially get the patent I know there's
pros and cons but other other ways
possible as well I feel like one can go
raw with one's idea to set a deal with
someone who feels it they're in need of
such an idea then a smartly designed
proposal may be playing wonders am i
right
so basically this I'm up do I need a
patent or can I just go in with a great
pitch and a great proposal here's the
thing Adarsh is a great question it
really depends on what your goal is
because a lot of inventors get screwed
out of money for their inventions
because they make bad business decisions
they go in without a pot here's what's
gonna happen I don't know what your
product is I don't let your idea is say
you see you have a new kind of headlight
for a car okay this is the best kind of
headlight ever you've invented this new
headlight the way that inventors will
typically make the most amount of money
and to get this product out there is to
license it to a car manufacturing
company it's not to go out and try to
build the headlights yourself and then
try to sell them to the Home Depot's of
the world it's to get in the actual car
manufacturing get a deal done and every
time they use your headlight they're
paying you a royalty that's the best way
to do it and then you can go on
inventing something else and you're paid
every time they sell a car with your
headlight so here's challenge those
that's the goal for a lot of inventors
okay the challenge is when you go and
you talk to a car company if you just go
with the proposal they're gonna say well
wow it's a great idea right if they
actually like it well it's a great idea
do you have a patent are you saying no
they're just gonna do it themselves
why do they need you they have a whole
team of engineers we're gonna say okay
engineers go build this and you can be
cut out of the deal and this happens all
the time
and inventors get get screwed out of
deals out of money because the companies
that they sell to realize hey we're good
just do this ourselves we don't need
this guy the only thing that protects
you is the patent now on top of that
here's what's gonna happen this idea of
a patent yes I have a patent oh great as
soon as you leave the room if they
really like your idea they're gonna turn
to their technical guys and say how can
we get around this patent is there a way
to build this headlight and not use his
patent can we get around that somehow
and if they can find the way they're
probably going to do it and again that's
cynical that that kind of sucks but
that's how a lot of these things go down
and unless you have the patent you're
not protected it's great to think that
if I put my idea out there and you know
people love it they're gonna want to
hire me they're gonna pay me for it
that's not how it usually works for a
lot of inventors and a lot of venters
end up becoming super jaded super
unhappy because they may even see their
inventions take off and somebody's
making millions off of it and they're
living at the poverty line because they
didn't get the patent for it and they
can enforce it and they didn't make good
business decisions so I don't want that
to be you if you have a great idea that
you think can work with a big company
then you need to have the patent to
protect yourself otherwise they're gonna
go right around you now in terms of
steps
patents are expensive right like you
have to really believe that this is
something that can change the world but
your first step can be getting a
provisional patent and it's a lot
cheaper and it gives you basically a
year to go out and prove that you can
commercialize this and you've a year to
go out and try to sell it you're gonna
go and try to make some money off of it
before deciding to get the full patent
or not
so if I were you if you had a great
business idea you have a great invention
that you've made that can change the
world
go get the patent and protect yourself
because that is what's going to help
bring you the money believe those are
watching let me know you think did you
get a patent are you thinking about a
patent leave a comment below I'd love to
hear your story if you like this video
thumbs up below click on my face
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much I'll see you soon